bonjour je m'appelle josé sarrazin je
suis chercheur en écologie matic et je
suis également responsable du
laboratoire environnement profond au
centre ifremer de brest
en fait mes études portent
particulièrement sur les écosystèmes
profonds des sources hydrothermales
alors ce sont des sources d'eau chaude
qui émergent à la surface du plancher
océanique comme des geysers dont les
températures peuvent atteindre à peu
près 300 400 degrés celsius et autour de
ses sources d'eau très chaude il ya une
vie extrêmement foisonnante qui se
développe en plein milieu de l'océan
profond c'est à dire à plus de mille
mètres de profondeur et c'est un peu de
savoir quelles sont les espèces qui
connaît ses sources hydrothermales et
comme dans quels types d'habitats ces
espèces peuvent vivre m'intéresse tout
particulièrement
donc pour ce faire on est obligé
d'utiliser des sous-marins puisqu'on est
dans les grandes profondeurs océaniques
et ses sous marins en fait qu'ils vont
nous aider à aller chercher nos
échantillons et à prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour caractériser les
habitats des espèces